the jogan experience we could never get
a normal job so my only paid job I ever
did was yeah medical trials checking
into hospitals and testing out drugs
that weren't on the market yet W yeah
you did that yeah I did that for two
years what they test out on you I I
stopped listening you know I was like
let him try it yeah yeah they would tell
me they're like oh this could happen
this could happen and I was like just
give me whatever I don't give a [__]
just give me some money Danny would have
crazy like side effects I like it was
like yellow once yellow now yeah yeah he
was like he was like once he was like we
well we have ad always shaking but Danny
was like once he was like this like I
went to visit him he was doing like
shaking and I was like you're right like
yeah side effect of the drug uh anyway
it was it was like a muscle Tremors all
up through my arm so I just couldn't
physically yeah I just what was that
drug I I literally dude I did not listen
to her they would tell me they would
send all these big pamphlets and we'd
have to sign a bunch of [__] but I would
never listen I would never know what I
was there for I would never do you have
any concern about doing that no I was
more excited to get
at the time 18 yeah that's the problem
yeah yeah you shouldn't let 18yar olds
make that decision yeah 18 to 20 is when
I did it well it was a way for you to
like and meet like people cuz there's a
lot of interesting people that would go
through there but I just hate injection
so I don't know I also did try and get
over my fear for injection cuz once they
take like administer the drug they have
to like get your blood every 15 minutes
so like they'd put the canulas in their
arm in your arm and they just keep
taking out blood taking out blood and
just testing whether or not things would
go wrong what was the worst side effect
you got he grew a third eye [__] if I
didn't I I um I remember it was they
were administering it with like a canul
it was it was a drip they were dripping
the injection the the drug in and it was
really [__] hurting and usually it
doesn't hurt usually I just like uh take
it or they administer it I didn't really
feel anything but it was painful and it
was hurting it was hurting I was like oh
God she's like are you all right I'm
like yeah yeah it's okay it's okay you
can keep yeah and I was like oh [__]
that really drills it was like felt like
someone was punching my arm did they
miss the vein and go the tissue it it
was like whatever happened was my whole
arm went paralyzed and I was like dude I
I'm like I can't I can't I can't move I
can't feel my hand I can't move my hand
she's like all right well just squeeze
my finger she put her finger there tell
try and squeeze it and I'm like oh I I
literally can't do it so she said like
all right quickly take the drug out and
they took the drug out and I was just
sort of sitting there with a paralyzed
arm and I probably sat there for like an
hour and once the drug had worn off I I
got my my feeling and you don't remember
what that drug was [__] I'm so sorry I
really I could dig it up my emails
probably but yeah how many different
drugs they try you well I did it for two
two three years so over 10 drugs I'd say
different things I tried it was like and
you go on there for like like group
likees of like four see I was doing the
work experience on set but I was mine
was free so Danny would do the stuff
that got the money for that I think
whatever that was the longest time I was
in hospital for it could range from 3
days in hospital to 2 months so yeah one
time I was in there for two months and
for what for the drugs so you just
stayed in the hospital for two months
while they administered drugs yeah yeah
and then they pretty much just uh wait
to see what the side effects are going
to be if they think you have to sleep in
the hospital and stay there yeah you
just stay there overnight how much do
they pay you for something like that 150
bucks a day 120 bucks a day between
Australian so so what that 100 us or
something like that less than that yeah
$90 USD a day for months yeah one to two
months
but no wait wait wait no it is crazy
like there was that famous case I don't
know if it was in where it was but the
the patients cuz they do it like in AOW
they old test one person then half an
hour later test another then another
right and then people started dying off
and like they knew was like going down
the line cuz like someone died half hour
that was like a fre the last guy and
they go in they go look look yeah you're
about to [__] die yeah look no
there's this side effect you're how many
people died what okay I I don't know
what story specifically this guy's
talking about but the trials that I was
checking to no one died the worst one I
heard of was they test it on mice before
they test it on the humans and they had
to bring everyone back into the trial
and say hey guys and I heard this from a
friend that recommended the trials to me
he's like guys we don't want anyone to
worry but um some of the mice have gone
blind and yeah so everyone was sort of
waiting to see if something was going to
[__] up their site but this was after
you'd already gotten the drug yeah well
it was a this is a friend's experience
yeah they'd had the drug and they
brought everyone back in like a week
later and they said some of the mice
have gone blind Jesus yeah yeah but you
know what what was the best part is when
the best part was when it blindness was
the best part no no the best part is
when the drug goes wrong and then you
get to leave early cuz You' have to stay
for the two months like all this Drug's
too dangerous we're not going to test it
and then you get paid for the full
amount wait wait wait wait wait that
makes no sense the drug goes wrong yeah
so like that one when they administered
it and my whole arm went paralyzed they
realized they couldn't administer that
drug to everyone else so the trial got
called off but you got paid for the full
month no longterm side effects no look
at
him I don't know I've never really
questioned it so you're looking at be
like I'm I'm crazy come on man what's
what's it's just the drug Tri well if
you pay attention to drug trials and
like how many drugs get approved and
then pulled because they find I me just
just after approval yeah and you're way
before approval yeah yeah you're guinea
pig I was yeah I was guinea pig was a
guinea pig after the guinea pigs yeah
yeah it was it was yeah it's a little
bit of a safety net to be like oh it's
tried on hamsters before
yeah but yeah it was it was pretty dodgy
but it was the only way that I could
make money